or madame veil il est à peine besoin de
vous rappeler qui vous êtes et ce que
vous représentez en france vous avez été
déportée quand vous étiez enfant et
pourtant vous n'avez jamais cessé de
prêcher la modération dès qu'il s'est
agi en france d'exhumer un passé qui au
fond au fond de la conscience collective
des français n'est pas toujours et
encore bien assumer alors pour vous
barbie prisonniers en france jugés en
france
est ce que c'est une bonne chose oui je
voudrais d'abord vous dire j'avais
beaucoup hésité à venir ce soir
depuis hier on m'a demandé dans beaucoup
de stations beau journalistes m'ont
demandé de donner mon sentiment sur
cette expulsion
et puis ce qui m'a décidé c'est lorsque
vous m'avez parlé de ce climat
passionnel lorsque j'ai lu que peut-être
ça donnerait lieu à des règlements de
compte que l'on a les exhumer des vielle
histoire franco-française et alors je
dois dire que ça m'inquiète autant comme
tout le monde peut être plus que
beaucoup je pense que c'est une
expulsion était souhaitable et qu'il
faut qu'il y ait un procès maintenant
exemplaire parce qu'il faut connaître
l'histoire et d'ailleurs on a beaucoup
parlé en disant c'est grâce au nouveau
régime en bolivie que barbie a été
expulsé que le problème est réglé en ce
sens me réjouis à cause de ça je crois
qu'il faut aussi se réjouir du
changement de régime parce que beaucoup
de boliviens sont sortis de prison aussi
grâce à ce changement de régime il faut
pas l'oublier
et il ne faut pas faire tourner
l'histoire autour d'un seul événement il
faut aussi penser au présent nous
l'oublions peut-être trop en pensant au
passé à ce qui s'est passé il ya 40 ans
mais le procès de bach mais le projet de
barreau l'occasion de réduire en valeur
un chapitre que les jeux doivent sylvie
oui mais je crois qu'il faut l'écrire
plus dans une perspective historique de
justice au sens traditionnel d'humour
parce que la justice au sens
traditionnel humeau elle n'a pas
tellement de place dans cette affaire
puisque des gens normalement
les crimes sont prêts sont prescrits et
qu'il a fallu des faits exceptionnels
des crimes contre l'humanité pour qu' il
n'y ait pas prescription il faut donc
rester dans ce caractère tout à fait
exceptionnel et je pense que si on a pas
prescrit les crimes contre l'humanité
c'est beaucoup plus dans un souci de
d'histoire on ne pas que les événements
recommence que dans le souci de
vengeance par rapport à un homme et donc
je crois que c'est vraiment à ce niveau
qu'il faut situer ce procès sans oublier
que comme vous venez de le rappeler il
ya eu depuis les procès de nuremberg
très peu de procès des ss aussi ayant
deux chats de la liste à pau ayant eu
des responsabilités aussi lourd et que
donc ce ne sera pas seulement un procès
qui concerne la france
enfin la justice française mais un
procès que l'on regardera depuis la
république fédérale d'allemagne depuis
tous les pays qui ont été occupés israël
que en israël on a fait un procès
exemplaire que le rap le procès du chien
a été menée dans des conditions aussi
yeux mais vous craignez au fond d'écran
florence les passions se greffent jeu
rien que je ressens que ce qui serait un
terrible c'est d'en faire une affaire
française avec l'occasion de rechercher
des des histoires qui elles sont
normalement prescrites et de remuer des
événements qui ne s'intègre pas dans
cette affaire là où qui s'y intègre bien
sûr mais de façon tout à fait tout à
fait annexe même pour des gens qui ont
souffert dans leur chair et vous en êtes
oui vous savez la prescription elle
couvre parfois les crimes abominables
des crimes d'enfants des crimes mais ce
sont des crimes individuels mais pour
les gens pour les parents qui en ont
souffert
c'est aussi grave ils ont souffert
autant même si ce sont des crimes de
droit commun que pour cette affaire là
donc je crois qu'elle doit si elle a
quelque chose exemplaire elle est
exceptionnel parce qu'elle salt est dans
un phénomène idéologique et je crois que
c'est ça qu'il faut faire ressortir au
cours du procès parce que c'est ce qu'on
a voulu c'est que ce n'est pas tellement
longue qu'on a voulu mettre en cause
bien sûr mais c'est surtout l'idéologie
idéologie d'ailleurs dont ils se
réclamaient encore récemment
en bolivie il était resté un nazi je
pense que c'est ça qu'ils font il faut
faire le procès est beaucoup plus que de
l'homme lui-même qui de toute façon sera
condamné à une peine qui ne peut
absolument pas être proportionnelle
offert ses fauteuils qui aurait intérêt
en france aujourd'hui à exploiter ce
français autrement
est ce que vous craignez vous une
expression et c'est pas une question
d'exploitation les choses peuvent venir
d'elle-même
il peut y avoir aussi des gens qui
veulent exploiter mais je crois que
quelques fois ci le déroulement des
d'une instruction peut donner lieu sans
qu'on veuille même à ce genre à ce genre
de de dérapages et je pense que ça au
trait à ce procès son sens qui est un
sens historique sa dignité
je ne sais même pas une époque où juge
parce qu' il peut y avoir eu d'autres
époques et ont dû à notre époque il
s'est passé dans certains pays des
choses qui ne sont pas comparables
peut-être mais qui tout de même ce qui
s'est passé au cambodge est aussi très
grave se convulse est une idéologie est
ce que cette idéologie
ce à quoi cette idéologie a conduit je
crois que c'est ça qui est important
c'est ça qui est important pour les
jeunes et pour pour que dans l'avenir
ils sont depuis ce pas se reproduire
on avait je vous remercie